immediately following the election
Google executives gathered to share
their feelings of dejection and despair
a video recently leaked to Breitbart
reveals the mindset of Google's
leadership from within their corporate
safe space this is co-founder Sergey
Brin you know it's nice that most people
here are pretty upset and pretty sad for
because of the election anyway I know
more serious note you know myself as an
immigrant and refugee I certainly find
the selection deeply offensive and I
know many of you do too
and and I think it's a very stressful
time and it conflicts with many of our
values values what are those Google
values after all this is a company that
has actively worked with the Chinese
communist regime for years and right now
Google is developing an app to screen
out content that the Chinese government
considers too sensitive for its citizens
translation Google is helping China
silence its political opposition the
Chinese government let's remember in
prisons dissidents and Christians daily
they have more than a million Muslims in
reeducation camps but the legitimate
election of President Trump
somehow conflicts with Google's vaunted
values give me a break today we learned
that a senior Google research scientist
named Jack Paulsen was so disgusted by
the company's collaboration with Chinese
censors that he has quit in protest and
I was thinking about this you want to
know the real reason that the Google
execs were so exercised so hurt by the
election of Trump because he promised to
hold Google's partner China accountable
to punish Chinese cheating on trade
feels that hollowed-out US manufacturing
for Google and many other big
manufacturers the pre Trump status quo
was much easier keep that production
overseas lower wages no regulations no
health care you have to worry about for
those employees over in China and if it
hurts America so be it
after all those blue-collar Americans
would probably be Trump voters anyway
and of course Google I hate you
deplorable that fear I think not just
the United States but around the world
is what's fueling concerns xenophobia
hatred and a desire for answers that may
or may not be there actually Trump's
found the answers are pretty easy
two words America first sure Trump will
work with the rest of the world he's
shown that but on a much more level
playing field so why is Google so
threatened by that I'll tell you why
history teaches us that there are
periods of populism of nationalism that
rise up and we get all the reason we
need to be in the arena that's why we
have to work so hard to make sure it
doesn't turn into a world war or
something catastrophic but instead is a
blip is it hiccup oh okay you stopped a
world war with your search engine that's
ridiculous
like the liberal elites across politics
academia and the entertainment industry
big tech doesn't really like the
American voters who turned out for Trump
that's pretty obvious Google thinks it
knows better than their customers after
all Google execs are richer than they
are people are leaving staff is crying
we're gonna lose
that was the first moment I really felt
like we were going to lose everybody if
you could turn around or go to the
person next to you and do a hug it works
that's worse than the sign of peace at
mass sorry I'm not a sign of peace
person hug group hug Trump one oh my god
I needed comic relief today that made me
laugh more than anything else but then
Huggy Bear Routh got down to business
our values are strong we will fight to
protect them and we will use the great
strengths and resources in reach we have
to continue to advance really important
values again the word values what values
is Google talking about well the
left-wing globalist values that have
helped enrich the oppressive shine
Chinese regime at the expense of free
expression and religious liberty and of
course made Google execs really rich
part of Google's disappointment was that
their efforts in 2016
failed really spectacularly of course
they claim that they're nonpartisan but
an email leaked to my colleague Tucker
Carlson showed that the tech giant tried
to turn out the Latino vote and 2016
because they were confident Latino
voters would support Hillary but can you
imagine their surprise when they wake up
up on election morning after the morning
at the election they see the 29% of
Latinos voted for Trump
they were gobsmacked Google it's not
some local business practicing civic
engagement we should all stand up and
Cheer Oh Google go Google is one of the
most powerful companies on the planet
they're responsible for about 90 percent
of all searches online they're more than
1.2 trillion searches on Google Google
each year globally more than 2 billion
people use its Android mobile platform
and they made a hundred and ten point
eight billion dollars in revenue last
year alone but when smaller companies so
other companies like chick-fil-a or
hobby lobby lobby or in an out burger
when they move in the smallest of ways
to support more traditional or even
conservative causes those companies are
sued and vilified non-stop by the
mainstream media when a giant like
Google pledges to actively undermine the
polluter
a will of the American people the media
don't cover it and you know why because
the media agree with the Google agenda
this is one of my favorite moments from
the Google anti-trump corporate rally is
there anything positive you see from
this election result ah boy that's
that's a really tough one right now
that's actually not so tough I love
those beanies by the way I want one get
one for my kids well is that so touch a
tough one anything good that comes out
of Trump's election well how's this try
on for size the economy's booming
fair trade deals are being negotiated
wages are rising and blue-collar America
is more optimistic about the future than
they've been for decades these Google
execs should have to do public acts of
penance for their petty idiotic
statements here's the bottom line the
Google gang and the rest of big tech
were happier when America was losing to
China they didn't care that blue-collar
America got poorer and communist China
got richer and stronger so long as
Google got richer in the process but
today President Trump is turning the
tables on that sick dynamic his policies
are working Google still rich of course
but the globalists even though the
economy is going well the globalists are
still grumpy that tells you all you need
to know and that's the angle